Welcome back to your Danish citizenship exam companion.
This is Chapter Five, Episode Five: music.
How far back does Danish music go?
The many large horns that have been preserved from the Bronze Age, which lasted from 1700 to 500 before Christ, suggest that music has been known in Denmark for several thousand years.
It is, however, not known with certainty what the beautiful so-called lurs, lurer, were used for.
They have been found in pairs, and posterity has tried to play on them, but how it is to be done is not known for sure.
In general, the information about music before the introduction of Christianity in the 900s is very sparse.
With Christianity came Catholic church music to Denmark, and after the Reformation in 1536, hymn singing, where the congregation was to sing along, became an important part of the church service.
The Reformation has therefore also been called the singing revolution, and the realm was gathered around hymnbooks that were authorised by the king and which everyone was to use.
The first came out in 1569.
Thomas Kingo, who lived from 1634 to 1703, Hans Adolph Brorson, 1694 to 1764, Nikolaj Severin Frederik Grundtvig, 1783 to 1872, and Bernhard Severin Ingemann, 1789 to 1862, are the most important hymn writers.
Their works range from hymns with a strong awareness that life is not eternal, that is Kingo, and a cultivation of an inward and emotional faith, that is Brorson, to hymns that praise nature, the child and life on earth as part of God's creation, that is Grundtvig and Ingemann.
Of these four, Grundtvig is the one to remember: he wrote a very large number of the hymns, salmer, in the Danish hymnbook, Den Danske Salmebog.
At the end of the 1700s and the beginning of the 1800s, several German musicians and composers immigrated to Denmark and renewed the music.
Friedrich Kuhlau, who lived from 1786 to 1832, wrote music for the national romantic festival play Elverhøi in 1828, which includes the music for the poet Johannes Ewald's "Kong Christian stod ved højen mast", "King Christian stood by the lofty mast", from 1778 to 79, one of Denmark's two national anthems and Denmark's royal anthem.
The text of "Kong Christian stod ved højen mast" was written in 1778 to 79 by Johannes Ewald, who lived from 1743 to 81.
Denmark is one of the only countries in the world to have two national anthems.
The other national anthem is "Der er et yndigt land", for which Adam Oehlenschläger wrote the text in 1819, and for which Hans Ernst Krøyer, who lived from 1798 to 1879, composed the music in 1835.
One of the best-known composers in the Højskolesangbog, the Folk High School Songbook, is Carl Nielsen, who lived from 1865 to 1931, and who had roots in a popular musical life on Funen.
With his operas, symphonies, chamber music and songs he became the most prominent Danish composer ever.
His music took its starting point in the romantic style of the 1800s, but he managed to unite the popular and the modern, and he worked with both simple and very complicated music.
Carl Nielsen was married to the sculptor Anne Marie Carl-Nielsen.
Danish jazz music has had outstanding musicians, bandleaders and composers from Leo Mathisen, who lived from 1906 to 69, to Palle Mikkelborg, born 1941, and the Danish-American Marilyn Mazur, born 1955.
In the 1960s Copenhagen was home to a number of American jazz musicians: for example Stan Getz, who sought an artistic refuge in Denmark for a period when the USA was marked by unrest and racial persecution.
In the 20th and 21st centuries, rock and pop music have had a very large audience.
Many different currents are in play, and the composer Bent Fabricius Bjerre, who lived from 1924 to 2020, became known for writing streams of melodies for films and TV series such as, for example, Matador.
Among the most important bands and musicians are Gasolin, Anne Linnet and TV2.
Gasolin, with the lead singer Kim Larsen, who lived from 1945 to 2018, combined pop and rock and contributed to the Danish song treasure with songs such as "Kvinde min", from 1975, and "Hva' gør vi nu, lille du?", from 1976.
Kim Larsen had a long career as a singer and songwriter, and many of his songs are used at family parties, because he can express feelings, humour and solidarity in a simple and subtly witty way.
Anne Linnet's song "Smuk og dejlig", from 1976, is about lesbian love, and the band TV2 from Aarhus, which self-ironically called itself "Denmark's most boring orchestra", sings about, among other things, everyday life, love and the importance of daring to live life and seize its opportunities.
Among TV2's best-known numbers is "Nærmest lykkelig".
In the 1990s the Danish-Norwegian music group Aqua had great success with their dance pop, where especially the number "Barbie Girl" was a global hit.
Aqua released two albums in their heyday, and with about 28 million CDs sold it is one of the best-selling Danish music groups ever.
In recent years, particularly the group Lukas Graham, with the lead singer Lukas Forchhammer, born 1988, at the head, has had great success both in Denmark and internationally.
The group released its first album in 2012, and the number "7 Years" is one of the highest-earning Danish numbers of the 2010s.
And Karen Marie Ørsted, born 1988, who is known under the artist name MØ, broke through with the single "Pilgrim" in 2013 and has since among other things released "Kamikaze" and "Final Song".
Together with the American band Major Lazer and the Canadian singer Justin Bieber she also released, in 2016, the single "Cold Water", which became a big international hit.
Denmark has won the Eurovision Song Contest, Det Europæiske Melodi Grand Prix, three times.
The first time was in 1963 with "Dansevise", which was performed by Grethe Ingmann, who lived from 1938 to 90, and Jørgen Ingmann, 1925 to 2015.
The second time in the year 2000, with "Smuk som et stjerneskud", "Fly on the Wings of Love", written and performed by the duo Brødrene Olsen, which consists of Jørgen Olsen, born 1950, and Niels Olsen, born 1954.
The third time was 2013, with "Only Teardrops", which was sung by Emmelie de Forest, born 1993.
In Danish: a composer is a komponist, a lead singer is a forsanger, hymns are salmer, and a national anthem is a nationalsang.
Here is your recap for Episode Five.
Grundtvig wrote a large number of the hymns in Den Danske Salmebog.
Lurs are Bronze Age horns, found in pairs; their use is not known.
The Reformation has been called the singing revolution; the first authorised hymnbook came out in 1569.
The most important hymn writers are Kingo, Brorson, Grundtvig and Ingemann.
Denmark has two national anthems: "Kong Christian stod ved højen mast", text by Johannes Ewald, which is also the royal anthem, and "Der er et yndigt land", text by Oehlenschläger from 1819 and music by Hans Ernst Krøyer from 1835.
Carl Nielsen, 1865 to 1931, is the most prominent Danish composer ever.
Gasolin, with Kim Larsen, Anne Linnet and TV2 are important pop and rock names.
Aqua's "Barbie Girl" was a global hit.
Lukas Graham's "7 Years" and MØ's "Cold Water" were international successes.
Denmark has won Eurovision three times: 1963, 2000 and 2013.
Now it is time for your exam practice.
These are real questions from past Danish citizenship exams on what you just heard.
For each one, I will read the question and the choices, then pause so you can pick your answer, and then I will give you the correct answer.
Question 1.
Who wrote a large number of the hymns in Den Danske Salmebog?
Option A: Herman Bang.
Option B: Ludvig Holberg.
Option C: N.F.S.
Grundtvig.
[DA] Hvem har skrevet et stort antal af salmerne i Den Danske Salmebog?  A: Herman Bang  |  B: Ludvig Holberg  |  C: N.F.S. Grundtvig
The answer is C: N.F.S.
Grundtvig.
It appeared in the June 2022 and June 2026 exams.
[DA] ✔ C: N.F.S. Grundtvig
Question 2.
Which pop group released the number Barbie Girl in the 1990s?
Option A: Whigfield.
Option B: Me and My.
Option C: Aqua.
[DA] Hvilken popgruppe udgav nummeret Barbie Girl i 1990’erne?  A: Whigfield  |  B: Me & My  |  C: Aqua
The answer is C: Aqua.
It appeared in the November 2022 and May 2024 exams.
[DA] ✔ C: Aqua
Question 3.
What was the lead singer in the band Gasolin called?
Option A: Kim Larsen.
Option B: Michael Bundesen.
Option C: Steffen Brandt.
[DA] Hvad hed forsangeren i bandet Gasolin?  A: Kim Larsen  |  B: Michael Bundesen  |  C: Steffen Brandt
The answer is A: Kim Larsen.
It appeared in the May 2023 and November 2025 exams.
[DA] ✔ A: Kim Larsen
Question 4.
What was Carl Nielsen, 1865 to 1931, especially known for?
Option A: He was a painter.
Option B: He was an architect.
Option C: He was a composer.
[DA] Hvad var Carl Nielsen (1865-1931) særligt kendt for?  A: Han var maler  |  B: Han var arkitekt  |  C: Han var komponist
The answer is C: He was a composer.
It appeared in the November 2023 and May 2025 exams.
[DA] ✔ C: Han var komponist
That's the end of this part.
Well done.